لن نتحدث الان عن المفاجاه بل عن ازمه
ويبدو وكان ماسك سيعود لمقارعه ابل يخطط
بحسب ابل انسايدر الحصول على المزيد من
الايرادات وتحديدا من مستخدمي ابل
مستخدموها يصنعون سيدفعون 11 دولارا بدلا
من ثمانيه للاشتراك في تويتر بلو الخطه
تشمل ايضا اجبار المستخدمين على الاشتراك
في الاعلانات وتتبع المنصه لهاواتهم وبيع
ارقام الهواتف في زياده الاراده وهذا
ينتحك العديد من الارشادات ابل ستور
وبالتالي الشركه لن تكون سعيده يبقى
السؤال لماذا يصير وماسك على اشعال حربا
مع ابل السر الثلاثين في المئه ثلث ارادات
الشركه من كل تنزيل وهو ما يجعل ماسك يرى
بان قفل الشركات ولذلك اعلانه عظمه على
تصنيعه هاتف النقاله لم يكن من باب
المنافسه لكنه ماسك ربما لا انا قفل هي
اكبر شركه في العالم وانها اساسا تحتفظ
باموال ورسوم التنزيل لاي تطبيق ولا تفرج
عنها لاصحابه قبل اقتطاع حصتها الثلاثين
في المئه في نظري ماسك ايضا هي اعلى عشر
مرات مما ينبغي وماسك مع تويتر في ماءزق
هناك ديون صفقه الاستحواذ 13 مليار دولار
وفوائدها مليار ومئتين مليون دولار سنويا
اكتشف ماسك الخطا على ما يبدو ولديه خطا
للتخلص من المنصه بعد ثلاث سنوات لكن قبل
التخلص يجب اولا استرجاع على 44 مليارا
التي اشترى بها المنصه ومن هنا جاءت رسوم
وتوفيق
[موسيقى]